in a completely  i i know i've i used this term last week  in another one of these kafka-esque  moments  here is cancun cruz republican senator  ted cruz  uh attacking john kerry for flying to  the climate conference last week on a  private jet and he points out  none of us have private jets and then  someone says actually uh ted  rob portman  does have a private jet um take a look  at this  john kerry has a private jet  that has flown dozens of times this past  year all around the country  i don't know about you but i don't have  a private jet i don't believe any of the  people on this stage have their own  private jet portman doesn't  one of the issues with making this  personal is you might have someone up on  the stage where the personal makes you  look like a hypocrite